let's take a look at how the exact
algorithm looks like
i have a recursive function where what
i'm looking for first
is if i have reached the maximum depth
that i
would like to render this means that if
i say that i would write to render
five bounces then this is going to be
five did i
did i reach this number of bounces yes
okay then just stop and return the
black color because this way is not
gonna continue
then what i'm looking for is the nearest
intersection
you remember from the previous lecture
that this means
parametric equations which i solved for
t
so what i'm interested in is that i am
intersecting a lot of objects
and i'm only interested in the very
first intersection
and if i didn't hit anything then i will
return a black color because there's no
energy
going in this through this way
now if i have the intersection of the
object i will
be interested in the emission and the
material of this object emission means
that if this is a light source then it's
going to have emission
and the material can be an arbitrary
vrdf diffuse
glossy or some complicated multi-layer
material this i'm going to store on them
what's up next well i would like to
construct a blue ray
because i will trace the next gray so i
can i
instantiate a new ray this will start
wherever i hit this object so if i hit
the table
i will create an array that starts from
the table
and i will set the outgoing direction
according to
some sample stream that i have let's say
that what they have here if it says that
random unit vector in the hemisphere off
where the object was hit and this sounds
like a diffuse case for me so
i generate a random unit vector on this
atmosphere
and this is going to be the outgoing
direction
now let's add together the elements of
the rendering equation
i have the cosine theta which is the
light attenuation
i have the brdf term and in the brdf
term it seems that here they have also
included this cosine theta part which is
the light attenuation
this is the albedo of the material
how much light is absorbed and how much
is reflected
and then what i would like to do is i
would call
the very same function that you see in
line of code number one so this is a
recursive function i will start the same
process again with the new rate the new
starting point and the new direction
and in the end if i have traced a
sufficient number of rays then i will
exit this recursion
and i collect the result of this in this
variable that's called reflected
and in the end this is the elegant
representation of the rendering equation
the emission the le plus the integrated
function which is the brdf
times this reflected which is all the
recursive
terms so this means that i shoot out
this ray in the hemisphere
and there's going to be many subsequent
bounces and i
add up all this energy into the
reflected
incoming light so this is the pseudo
fault this is
not this is not something that you
should try to compile or anything like
that but this is what
we will code during the next lecture
this is just a schematic overview on
what is happening exactly
it's actually very true we shoot array
we bounce into the scene and then we
hopefully hit a light source at some
point
and even if we hit the light source we
continue
but hitting the light source is
important because this is where the
emission term comes from
let me show you what's what's going on
if we don't hit light sources
so this l e is the emission term on the
left side here
so we add this to the end result at
every recursion step
and the fundamental question is that if
we have a long life path that doesn't
hit the light source
we are using completely random standing
or maybe some smart important sampling
well then we never we will never have
this emission term
what does this mean that the radiance
that we
give we get from the program is going to
be zero
so the corollary of this is that
only you will get gradients you will get
an output from only light paths
that heat a light source if you don't
hit the light source you
don't know where the light is coming
from so you will return a black pixel
and this is obviously a really bad thing
because you're computing churning out
samples and samples and samples perhaps
on your gpu
but it doesn't return you anything
so it's a very peculiar fact about
simple naive path tracing
is that if you have a small light source
the convergence
of your your final image is going to be
slower
why someone help me out
smaller light sources more variants
slower convergence because we need a
random rays to hit the light source
isn't it small then we won't hit it as
often exactly
exactly so the relative probability of
keeping the light source is going to be
less
for a small light source and up to the
extreme where we have a point light
source
and if we have a point like source then
we will see that we will be in trouble
because what i would expect from my path
tracer is to return something like this
while imagine a point light source in
here
but this is not what we will end up with
so i would expect it to return the
correct result many people have reported
many forums on the internet that hey i
implemented it but
this is what i got and wow this doesn't
work at all
i mean all these pronouns law smells
like total internal reflection
monte carlo integration for a black
image i mean i could generate this with
five lines of c plus plus
why why do we even bother we will get
nothing
why is that point light source
black image why
yes
exactly so a point
represents a location in mathematics it
does not have
area so technically it is
the same getting the point by source is
impossible
because this is the same as what you
study in statistics and probability
theory that if you have
one number in a continuous scale what is
the probability of hitting this number
zero because that's the point it has no
surface area it's infinitely small
you cannot hit it
so this is the reason of your black
image if you read the forums on the
internet you'll find
plenty of this
now we could also sum up our findings
internet meme style if you will so if
you would like
to compute pathways with a point light
source
without the technique that is called
next event estimation
then you usually will expect a wonderful
image but this is what you will get
now the first question is obviously how
do we overcome this
what we can do is that every time we hit
something some object in the scene be it
diffuse
or anything but not light sources we
compute the direct effect of the light
source
on this point in the scene
so this is a schematic to show what is
going on so i start from the viewer
i hit this sphere and i don't just
start tracing the new ray outwards but i
will connect this point to the light
source
and i will compute a direct illumination
term
this is the schematic for path tracing
without the next event estimation
and this is with next event estimation
so at every station
i connect to the light source in this
case this is actually occluded
in this case this is debatable and in
the third bounce you will get
some contributions from the light source
question is how do we do this exactly
well
this is the topic this was the topic of
assignment zero
so the formula that you see in the
assignment 0 is exactly the very same
thing as what you should be using
what was in there well what we were
interested in is
that there was a term with with the four
pi
because if you have a light source
that's a sphere then what you would
then we are interested in how much
radiance is emitted in one direction
so then you will need to divide by the
area
of the surface which is division by four
pi
and there's going to be the attenuation
term
which is r squared same as in the
gravitational law
or in the law of electric fields it
means that the further away
i am from the light source the less
light is going through
this is a really good technique because
of multiple
reasons and one of the reasons is that
you will
get contributions from every bounce
during
the computing to life before i proceed i
would like to tell you that
here this l we are talking about this ld
the emission term and we are adding this
part
of this emission term in every bounce so
if i hit p1 i add this something if i
hit p2 i add this something if i hit p3
then i also add to something but
when i hit the light source i don't add
the emission term anymore
because i will be adding it again so
this one led that you would add when you
hit the light source by chance
this is distributed into individual
purposes
why is this great one you can remember
point light sources because the direct
effect you can actually measure but you
cannot hit the light source itself
so that's okay two you will have less
variance
because it's not like i either hit the
light source or i don't
i statistically always will pick the
light source unless there are occluders
so i'm adding many samples with small
variances not one sample
and lottery because you either mean or
you don't get anything back so
i can lower the variance which means
that
my images will convert faster and the
other thing is that
because there are contributions of every
balance i can
separate direct and indirect modulation
so
a lot of people do this in the industry
because
the movie industry is nowadays using
path pricing i cannot say that
like as an all-encompassing something
statement but for instance disney is now
using global illumination in that mostly
countries
why because it looks insanely good and
it is very simple
and it took them more than 20 years
for them to replace their old system
which they really liked it was called
case
and now they are using global
illumination processing it has taken a
long time but the benefits of global
illumination
are now too big to test something
and what they are doing is that they get
a physically based result
but this is not always what the artists
are looking for
because if you have work together with
artists
then they will say okay you have
computed a beautiful image but i would
like
the shadows to get a bit brighter
you will as the engineer say that while
this is not possible i computed what
would happen in physical reality and
that's it
but the artists are not interested in
physical reality they are interested in
their own thoughts and their own
artistic vision and they would like to
change the shadows
so you could technically make one of the
light sources
brighter and then the shadows would get
brighter but then the artist says hey
don't change anything else in the scene
just change the shadows
and then you could pull out your
knowledge of the rendering equation that
look
the radians coming out from this point
you cancel its surroundings
so you cannot just make something
brighter and the nearby things will also
get brighter you cannot
circumvent them when you can what you
can do with the next event destination
is that
you take you generate an image from the
first balance
so you will get one image which is which
you
deposit the radians that you measured in
p1 that's an image
and then you create another image which
will only contain the second
bounces p2 and upwards so you would have
multiple images
and you could technically just add up
all of these images with simple addition
and you would get physical reality
great but if the artist says that i want
stronger indirect illumination
then you would grab this buffer this
image that holds up the second
and the higher order bounces and you
could do some photoshop or you could do
whatever you want with that without
touching anything else
so you have a nice separation for direct
and indirect illumination
moving in the sorry the movie industry
they love it
they are playing with it all the time
and in the
later you will see some algorithms that
behave differently only indirect
elimination and differently on direct
illumination
you can only do that if you separate
these terms
so let's see path tracing now with next
event destination i have the very first
bounce
and before i continue my ray i
will send the classical super super
classical
shadow ray to the light source a
randomly chosen point of the light
source
and i will add this direct contribution
of the light source to this point
and then i continue
let's go back to the terms sorry we use
many terms for the very same thing this
is why i'm writing all of these terms
because if you read the forums if you
read papers
you will see these terms and they all
mean the same
so explicit light sampling max demand
destination
very same thing so i continue my ray
and i also hit the light source with the
shadow ray
and then i continue on and on and on and
imagine that this
third one is an outgoing way that
actually hits the light source
and if i do i don't add the lp turning
there
because i did in the previous process
it's very important to know
now you have seen the results for a
point light source
nothing versus something that's pretty
hefty
but even if you have a reasonably big
light source like the lifeline
size light source i told you that you
can
have a variance suppression effect as
well
so this is some amount of samples per
pixel i think it's
two maybe three samples per pixel so
this means that i grab one pixel
and i send three rays through it so it's
three multi-parallel samples now
this you can do in two different ways
because if you start to use renderers
then
you will see how this exactly happens
some renderers
are rendering tiles so what they do is
that
they start with some pixels and if you
say i want 1000 samples per pixel
then it will start take one or four or
whatever number of threads
you have on your machine it could take
four seven four pixels
and it will shoot more and more samples
to it and
after it got to 1000 samples
it will stop and show you a really good
and converged pixel and what we call
progressive rendering is the opposite
you pick one pixel you shoot array
through it but only one
and then you go to the next and then you
go to the next
and then you will see an image that has
some amount of noise and
progressively you will get less and less
voice so this is what you see here
is progressive rendering
emotion now no next event estimation so
we only get contributions if we hit this
light source at the end
somewhere if we don't you will get a
black sample
now look closely this is with next event
estimation
so there's a huge difference such a
simple technique
can speed up the rendering of many
scenes with
orders of magnitude
you can also play with this program by
the way this is implemented on shader
toy
so when you read this at home just click
on the link
and play with it it's amazingly fun